this should not be a partisan issue  there is not a democratic or republican  value in one single act of these  shooters it's not  but people in power  have failed to act so we're asking you  and i'm asking you will you please ask  yourselves  can both sides rise above  can both sides see beyond the political  problem at hand and admit that we have a  life preservation problem on our hands  we got a chance right now to reach for  and to grasp a higher ground above  our political affiliations a chance to  make a choice that does more than  protect your party  a chance to make a choice that protects  our country now and for the next  generation  we got to take a sober humble and honest  look in the mirror  and re-rebrand ourselves based on what  we truly value  what we truly value